il ya comme cela des loisirs que nous
pratiquons à mi chemin entre
l'amateurisme le professionnalisme c'est
le cas de marie christine coulon qui
trouve refuge dans la peinture de
tableau que lui inspire son entourage
quotidien sans verser dans l'obligation
de résultat un cherche en même temps
qu'à se fait plaisir a sans cesse
améliorer son coup de pinceau dans un
arc à la découvert et aimé dès son plus
jeune âge
quand est ce que vous trouvez le temps
de peindre et puis de vraiment de vous
donner complètement à la peinture
puisque vous ne faites pas que ça oui
alors ben je vole du temps oui sur lui
tant que je n'aurai peut-être consacrer
à ma famille et à mon sommeil surtout en
fait parce que c'est vrai que moi ça ne
me dérange pas de me réveiller à 4
heures du matin et de sauter sur les
pinceaux je sais que de quatre heures à
5 heures et demie ça me sens fait un
petit temps pour peindre c'est qu'un
ennemi bon bah je commence à aller
m'occuper du café des enfin du petit
déjeuner les enfants et cetera
si je rentre chez moi midi pour manger
ben je suis capable d'avaler un truc
vite fait et de retourner à la peinture
c'est un véritable passion car oui mais
moi je si je pouvais si je pouvais vivre
de ma peinture si je pouvais
de savoir si recalés ne faire que ça je
le ferai puis le ferai ouais est ce que
vous croyez que ça va ça peut être
possible de dire que de la peinture je
pense que c'est possible pour pour
certaines personnes mais j'en suis pas
ce niveau là à quoi je n'en suis que je
suis bien consciente que c'est c'est un
plaisir égoïste
je pars parce que j'aime bien ça je me
rends compte que ça plaît certaines
personnes mais
il est hors de question que j'arrête mon
boulot pour me mettre à la peinture à
100% donc en parallèle vous adonner en
parallèle de travail oui je travaille
bien sur wii
je suis formatrice à leur part je
m'occupe des dés des futurs secrétaire
donc d'un futur secrétaire qui vont être
sur le marché
en quelques années donc passe par une
préparatoire et c'est moi qui m'en
occupe pas s'adonner en tout cas comment
vous définissez votre style de peinture
alors haussé de la peinture naïve oui le
sait le style naïf que je pas
et d'un autre côté vous ma peinture a
quand même évolué depuis l'année
dernière où je me suis un peu à fond et
je mélange un peu d'impressionnisme avec
naïf trouve ça pas trop mal ça paraît et
là encore
c'est le style naïf en fait parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de couleurs et on travaille
pas sur les jeux de lumière pas trop
tout cas quelles sont vos sources
d'inspiration alors mes sources
d'inspiration
c'est ce qui m'entoure en général c'est
souvent aussi les petites histoires
créole puisque moi j'ai vécu un petit
moment en métropole c'est vrai que des
fois quand j'avais mes parents au
téléphone mes soeurs et frères suffisait
qu'il donne un petit mot et autres je
partais j'imagine aider des petites
histoires ou alors ça me rappelait aussi
des moments d'une enfance par exemple
mais je brodait et je me faisais tout à
cinéma elle et toi
ce qui est important c'est que on prend
pas le même pinceau pour faire tout le
tableau
on a toute une gamme de pinceaux en
fonction de ce qu'on fait par exemple là
si je fais un petit trait ici je suis en
train de faire veto tous les ans les
petits traits et ben je vais voyez là je
vais prendre un petit pinceau qui est
assez fin et les fins pinson est pareil
je prendre un pinceau encore plus faim
pour faire le tour des visages et ce
sera un pinceau à 3 kwc alors d'accord
ni plus ni moins et là il reste comme
est de travailler à préférer ce tableau
on peut pas savoir on peut pas savoir
jamais jamais parce que moi ça m'est
arrivé de terminer soit disant un
tableau puis
deux semaines après devoir du diamant or
il manque quelque chose et hop ou alors
j'arrête je l'enlève ce que j'ai mis et
puis je mets autre chose par exemple la
sagesse ce personnage là j'ai travaillé
trois quatre fois
avant elle avait débordé du val it est
le plus grosse elle avait la tête
tournée autres membres gino non on va la
tournée de toutes façons on va
travailler c'est pas terminé les
couleurs sont pas terminés la main par
exemple c'est trop franc cette couleur
là c'est ça c'est trouve alors que je
travaille au 6 septembre là pour la
réaliser réalisation de ce tableau
j'ai fait des petits croquis n'a pas
parce que je voulais mettre sur les
tables bancs
des carafes des verts tout un tas de
choses et donc j'ai voulu mettre une
petite lampe sais pas si vous vous
souvenez des
mandarines en plantant clemens a des
petites carafe à whisky et cetera le
soin champagne voilà qu'il a et qui se
retrouve ici dans le tableau qui ronge
étudie un petit peu je fais des croquis
et après je
je le mets sur
sur le tableau là c'est une scène de
marché c'est un tableau que j'ai fait et
qui est exposé et donc aux galeries mais
à la fin ça donne pas du tout ça en fait
un jeu fait plusieurs plusieurs études
le ce personnage là apparaît il ya
d'autres choses il ya deux personnes qui
apparaissent sur le marché avec beaucoup
de couleurs de couleurs etc
ça ce sommet mais baigneuses qui sont là
elle nous reconnaît celle là et puis les
mains d'autres que j'ai mise ou pas
voilà ça c'est les champs de tournesols
je voulais mettre des filles dans un
ancien de tendance j'ai fait plusieurs
petits là de deux copines qui mangent
ici yad'autres
la barque ou qui débarque alors ça ce
petit personnage et sur un de mes
tableaux exposer en galerie c'est une
petite fille qui semble église et elle
est exposée c'est une façon pour vous de
vous exprimer
oui un peu oui oui une façon de
communiquer avec les autres en tout cas
oui le montrer ma façon à moi de voir
les choses de voir la vie et comment ça
se passe pour les choix des couleurs le
but personnages sont tous bronzés tous
noirs oui
c'est un choix c'est un choix sa joie
parce que je suis je pas m'embêter
affaires différentes couleurs moi je
vois tous les ans pareil d'accord donc
je vois pas pourquoi dans mes tableaux
je vais chercher des teintes différentes
si au niveau des lumières par exemple
quand un visage et explose et d'une
certaine façon il ya une lumière un
endroit et un autre endroit n'y a pas de
lumière c'est tout sinon ils sont tous
pareils d'accord et ils sont tous bien
enveloppé aussi ce que j'estime que la
vie
vaut la peine d'être vécue il faut il
faut en profiter il faut pour manger il
faut bien vivre donc sont tous bien
enrober les uns et
tous noirs d'accord voilà
c'est ça c'est ce qui est
caractéristique de ma peinture il ya
autre chose aussi c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
de visage tous mes personnages alors
comment vous expliquez ça joue pareil
c'est toujours une certaine harmonie
pour moi quand tu regardes
quelqu'un je m'intéresse à ce qu'il ya
un tout en fait un tout pas seulement
aux traits d'un chasseur et tous mes
personnages n'ont pas de visage parce
que je me dis tiens peut-être que intel
va se reconnaître et effectivement des
fois quand je parle des petites scènes
vécues avec des amis je dis ça te
rappelle rien ça 10 à 6 mois ça sinon
ils se reconnaissent enfin et c'est
rigolo mais il ya que qui vont se
reconnaître c'est des scènes que vous
visez un fake dm que je vis et des
scènes que j'améliore bien sûr parce que
moi peut dire non plus que tout et est
réelle mais des scènes que jamais des
hommes et on peut dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de vous dans vos tableaux toujours oui
je sais en fait je sais pas moi perdre
quelques choses ki ve ca vient pas à
l'esprit en tout cas de panne quelque
chose sans qu'ils aient une part une
part de vérité ou part de ma vie
confesse et toujours c'est un peu
égoïste peut-être donc le guerrier qui
attrapera le plus gros poisson portera
la coiffe de guerre et il sera le chef
pendant et les journées entières ils
sont optimistes et son prêt conscience
déjà de votre passion ah oui comme elle
se comporte alors en fait j'ai redémarré
la peinture il ya peu de temps parce que
mon chevalet
et met les tubes de couleurs ou sont
restés dans un coin un bon moment parce
que j'avais pris la décision d'avoir des
enfants enfin les enfants sont arrivés
comme ça jiwa et là je me suis rendu
compte que c'était
que je voulais profiter de mes gamins
d'accord je ne voulais pas aller les
compatibilités les deux oui c'était pas
possible de perdre et d'élever les
enfants en même temps et c'est venu
naturellement je n'aime pas eu à me
poser la question choisi j'ai pris tout
mon matériel j'ai mis dans un coin et je
me suis occupé de mes enfants et ça
quand même duré cinq ans puisque j'ai
deux enfants de 6 et 3 ans et demi ça a
duré cinq ans pendant cinq ans j'ai pas
touché à un pinceau ça n'a pas manqué
non
bon donc j'étais dedans ça va pas
manquer et c'est après c'est quand je me
suis remise ya quelques temps je me suis
dit mais comment tu fais pour vivre sans
ça c'est impossible mais je pense
qu'elle est une compensation
j'avais jamais d'autres choses à faire
mes enfants m'apporter beaucoup un
équilibre aussi donc j'avais pas besoin
de peinture maintenant elles grandissent
les deux sens à l'école et ça correspond
pile avec que l'entrée à l'école de la
deuxième fête le fait que je reprenne le
peinture dès qu'elle est entrée à
l'école hop j'ai repris les pinceaux
qu'est ce qu'ils chantent des indiens
commun chambre
quand une chanson hélène comment faire
attiches autour du feu ans au moins ouah
qu'est ce que vous aimez qu'on vous dise
quand on voit par
là qu'on me dise la vérité
que ce soit
négatif ou positif il ya eu des gens qui
m'en diras ce fond noir gêne pas du tout
qu'on mettait pas du fond blanc je suis
désolé mais c'est ma façon à moi de
peindre il semblait pas je le comprends
tout à fait je peux pas plaire à tout le
monde ma peinture ne peut pas plaire à
tout le monde parce que vous avez des
projets concernant vos tableaux alors
vas exposition l'année prochaine
d'accord ok donc au cadre noir fin juin
oui les rliss âges et tous niveaux de
juillet normalement
si j'arrive bien sûr à produire
suffisamment de tableaux etc enfin je
pense que je vais pouvoir le faire mais
bon si jamais là